[Musik]
die nachrichten des tages heute nichts
häufig dienstag der erste februar guten
abend und willkommen norbert lehmann ist
auch wieder dabei für den sponsor von
und das sind die wichtigsten themen von
heute
muskelspiele in der ukraine krise es war
aber auch ein tag der diplomatischen
offensive
impfpflicht im gesundheitswesen
eigentlich soll sie ab mitte märz gelten
aber die gesundheitsämter fühlen sich
mit der kontrolle überfordert
haftbefehle nach polizistenmord die
tatverdächtigen von kusel wollten
offenbar ihre wilderei vertuschen
wir beginnen mit dem ukraine konflikt da
wird heute auf unterschiedlichsten
ebenen versucht die krise friedlich zu
lösen telefonisch zwischen moskau und
washington der britische premier ist in
kiew der ungarische regierungschef in
moskau alle seiten betonen keiner wolle
einen krieg in europa trotzdem gehen die
mobilisierungen weiter florian neumann
berichtet die größte herausforderung
hier ist wohl das wetter marie estland
minus fünf grad schlechte sicht seit
einer woche patroullieren hier sechs us
amerikanische und vier belgische
kampfjets den luftraum die nato
verstärkt ihre militärpräsenz im osten
und will dass die öffentlichkeit das
mitbekommt
das ist ja kein geheimnis dass das hier
eine reaktion ist auf die russischen
aktivitäten die jets unterstützen uns
beim schutz unseres luftraums und sie
zeigen die solidarität der nato in ihrer
politischen mission derweil in kiew in
der ukraine erst kommt der polnische
premierminister dann der britische beide
mit konkreten zusagen im gepäck ist
nicht mehr wie wir sind bereit der
ukraine raketen flugabwehr leichte
moerser aufklärungsdrohnen artillerie
munition und andere verteidigungswaffen
zu liefern
wir haben sanktionen vorbereitet wir
stellen militärische unterstützung
bereit und wir verstärken unsere
wirtschaftliche zusammenarbeit
zur selben zeit in moskau stellt sich
auch die frage wie einig der westen
auftritt als erster chef eines nato
staates trifft ungarns premier orban den
russischen präsidenten putin in dieser
krise persönlich prompt stellt autobahn
in frage ob sanktionen überhaupt
sinnvoll sind und putin wirft den usa
vor russische sicherheitsinteressen zu
ignorieren
ihr hauptanliegen ist viel entwicklung
russlands zu behindern darum geht es
ihnen ihre wird muss dafür ist die
ukraine nur ein instrument
zugleich aber zeigt putin sich offen für
weitere gespräche mit dem westen auch
wenn es nicht einfach wird
christian sam ist für uns in der ukraine
in kiew wie geht die ukrainische
regierung mit dieser bedrohungslage um
christian
herr präsident sie lenski der muster ein
spagat versuchen wie bei den gesprächen
heute muss er natürlich weiter versuchen
um internationale unterstützung zu
werben weil die ukraine das braucht
finanziell und militärisch
er hat außerdem angekündigt dass er das
ukrainische militär aufstocken will
andererseits dritter hier rhetorisch auf
die bremse und sagt eine russische
invasion die stunden nicht unmittelbar
bevor ihm ist es wichtig hier keine
panik zu verbreiten
die sorge ist groß ist die menschen dann
doch auf die straße rennen das die
menschen zu den banken rennen und
vielleicht ihre konten leerräumen mal
die sorge von der wirtschaftskrise dass
die inflation weiter steigt dass die
landeswährung griwna abgewertet wird das
würde die ukraine stark treffen insofern
versucht er da auf die bremse zu treten
er stützt sich bei seiner aussage auch
auf die aussagen der russischen geheim
der ukrainischen geheimdienste die ihm
sagen dass stünde nicht unmittelbar
bevor das sagt er dafür kriegt der
kritik auch von internationaler seite
auch von den usa und auch intern aus der
ukraine gibt oppositionsgruppen
kritisieren ihnen dafür dass er da das
doch zu leicht nehmen würde und die
gefahren nicht sieht also er muss immer
darauf achten wenn er eine äußerung
macht das die zwei wirkung hat nach
außen und nach innen
dankeschön für diese einschätzung live
aus kiew christian selber das zu corona
die pandemie bringt die deutschen
behörden immer wieder an ihre grenzen
das zeigt sich im moment auch bei der
impfpflicht für beschäftigte im
gesundheitswesen die gilt eigentlich ab
mitte märz allerdings sind die
gesundheitsämter mit der kontrolle wohl
überfordert susanne seidel hatte price
stephanie poser fürchtet um ihren job im
seniorenheim st hedwig in wittenburg
gegen korona will sie sich nicht impfen
lassen sie sei allergikerin und fürchte
die gesundheitlichen folgen doch mit dem
herannahen des 16 märz steigt der druck
enorm es gibt ja nur noch ist so geimpft
oder beziehungen nicht geimpft als sind
so 22 klassen und ich finde die
spaltungen extrem und sind wir trotzdem
immer noch menschen und ich sag mal wir
tragen die maske wir lassen und testen
und ich finde das sollte dann auch kurz
von 72 mitarbeitenden in dem von der
caritas geführten heim wollen sich 13
nicht impfen lassen bis das
gesundheitsamt über sie entscheidet
werden sie aber noch weiter arbeiten
können die unsicherheit bleibt natürlich
bestehen dass ich denke dass dieses
gesetz dann auch umgesetzt wird sonst
macht es ja keinen sinn dieses gesetz zu
erlassen und die frage ist ja wie lange
habe ich die mitarbeiter noch zur
verfügung und abwandern auch nicht mehr
die gesundheitsämter sollen in jedem
einzelfall entscheiden wie es mit dem
mitarbeitenden weitergeht doch dafür
fehlten handlungsanweisungen und
personal die sachbearbeiterinnen und
sachbearbeiter werden entscheiden müssen
was ist jetzt wichtiger die durchsetzung
die einrichtungs bezogenen impfpflicht
und das betretungsverbot für die
ungeimpften oder die
versorgungssicherheit beispielsweise in
einem alten und pflegeheim
gesundheitsministerin stefanie drese
will die ämter da unterstützen mir geht
es darum den leuten vor allem einen
handlungsleitfaden an die hand zu geben
für einfache für normale für schnell zu
regeln gefälle es wird aber auch
juristisch schwierige dinge geben denn
das risiko dass viele ungeimpfte gegen
das beschäftigungsverbot klagen könnten
ist groß
unterdessen steigen die korona zahlen
weiter die inzidenz liegt heute bei über
1.000 2 100 und die dunkelziffer dürfte
beträchtlich sein denn viele infektionen
werden wohl nicht mehr gemeldet ein
möglicher grund viele menschen sind
ratlos wenn ihr schnell test positiv ist
dürfen sie dann überhaupt noch einen
genaueren pcr test machen ist der
kostenlos wie lange muss man aufs
ergebnis warten elisabeth schmidt hat
antworten
corona abstriche in der hausarztpraxis
uwe langenfeld in osnabrück jeden tag
fragen in seine patienten ob sie
überhaupt noch an den pcr test machen
dürfen die verunsicherung ist groß
es ist schwierig für insgesamt sind fast
täglich neue regelungen und insofern
weiß man gar nicht was man eigentlich
will fordern veranstalten so es ist
richtig viel los weil es hat geheißen
die die korona test wort und wird
geändert und 17 anders gemacht und sie
hören nicht auf also die belastung für
uns ist extrem stark dabei ist noch
alles beim alten corona waren brot oder
symptome dann hat ein patient anspruch
auf einen kostenlosen pcr test für die
neue test verordnung geplant alle haben
weiter anspruch allerdings sollen die
labore die pcr tests priorisiert
auswerten honorable gruppen sowie
medizinisches und pflegepersonal haben
dann voran alle anderen müssen wohl
länger als 24 stunden auf ihr
testergebnis warten die labore sind am
limit und ich erwarte in den nächsten
wochen insbesondere im süden der
bundesrepublik eine weit ein weiteres
ansteigen der test zahlen und dann ist
es halt eben wichtig dass wir diese
priorisierung dann entsprechend machen
der run auf die pcr tests hat auch
diesen grund bislang gilt in deutschland
nur derjenige als offiziell infiziert
der an den positiven pcr test nachweisen
kann der bund plant künftig soll das
auch durch zertifizierte antigen
schnelltests möglich sein
23 mal testen die guten schnelltest
können nach wie vor infektionen die hohe
viruslast haben und damit die
infektionen die am ehesten zu
übertragungen weiter übertragungen nach
essen trotzdem schnelltests seien nur
eine überbrückungshilfe auf eine lösung
des pcr test problems wartet deutschland
weiter
reisen ohne booster impfung in der eu
ist ab heute deutlich schwieriger denn
die eu imf nachweise sind ohne
auffrischungsimpfung nur noch neun
monate gültig danach werden nicht
gepostete bei reisen in ein anderes
eu-land wie ungeimpfte behandelt in der
regel bedeutet das sie brauchen einen
aktuellen negativen test oder sie müssen
in quarantäne
was genau sich ab heute für reisende in
der eu ändert die neuen regeln finden
sie unter zdf heute oder in der zelle
erfreute app hier erfahren sie auch was
man noch beachten muss wenn man jetzt in
den urlaub fährt
bemerkenswerte zahlen gibt es vom
arbeitsmarkt sie liegen wieder fast auf
dem niveau wie vor der pandemie im
januar waren zwei millionen
462.000 menschen ohne job das sind zwar
133.000 mehr als im dezember aber der
anstieg ist für die jahreszeit
historisch niedrig die arbeitslosenquote
liegt bei 5,4 prozent im vergleich zum
januar letzten jahres gibt es
439.000 weniger arbeitslose
wer zum jahreswechsel förderung für
energieeffizientes bauen beantragt hatte
der brauchte in den vergangenen tagen
starke nerven vor einer woche stoppte
wirtschaftsminister habe das programm
überraschend hintergrund war eine
antragsflut bei der förderbank kfw denn
nur noch bis ende januar so hatte es
noch die vorgänger regierung kurzfristig
entschieden sollten neubauten mit nicht
ganz so hohen standards unterstützt
werden für einen teil der bauern
bauherren gibt es nun hoffnung ina
baltes
energieberater microm hat seit wochen
geschuftet für den 31 der stichtag für
die förderanträge seiner kunden die
bauen wollen doch schon sieben tage
vorher wurden die anträge einfach nicht
mehr angenommen wumms kunden empört
fassungslosigkeit und entsetzen also das
war jetzt gott sei dank alles ohne
vorwurf an uns wir waren genauso gut
überrascht von der situation und
ja das ist für den normalen
einfamilienhaus bauer ist das sicherlich
viel geld 26 1250 euro stehen also zur
debatte für mehrfamilienhäuser geht es
um hunderttausende in teilen nimmt der
minister den förderstopp heute zurück
wer bis zum 24 erst eingereicht hat soll
doch geld bekommen für diejenigen die
sich jetzt wahrscheinlich sehr ärgern
dass sie einen tag oder eine woche zu
spät sind bei der antragstellung gibt es
die perspektive dann mit einer
veränderten antrags kulisse weiter
gefördert zu werden die anträge müssen
umgestellt werden doch umstellen heißt
im klartext noch mehr energie sparen das
ist viel teurer und braucht neue
planungen das politische hin und her hat
die branche stark verunsichert seitdem
andere der neuen bundesregierung wurde
von uns verlangt kapazitäten aufzubauen
zu investieren dafür brauchen wir
planungssicherheit die haben wir erstmal
ein wahnsinnig vertrauensverluste
erstmal verkraftet werden muss für die
die ihre baupläne nicht umstellen können
ist nicht klar wie es weitergeht und
wenn dann doch gebaut wird ohne
fördergelder muss gespart werden
vielleicht zu lasten der
energieeffizienz
als verstörend bezeichnet heute der
staatsanwalt den doppelmord an zwei
polizisten gestern eine 24 jährige
beamtin und ihr kollege wurden offenbar
erschossen um wilderei zu vertuschen
gegen die beiden verdächtigen erging
haftbefehl wegen gemeinschaftlichen
mordes marion geiger und anna duda
berichten
kaiserslautern heute mittag einer der
tatverdächtigen nach der vorführung beim
ermittlungsrichter
dieser erließ haftbefehl wegen mordes
gegen den 38 jährigen andreas s und
seinen mutmaßlichen komplizen einen
32-jährigen
der ermittlungsrichter geht davon aus
dass die tat
gemeinschaftlichen mord darstellt
dass diese tötung der beiden
polizeibeamten dazu diente die
vorangegangene jagdwilderei zu verdecken
auf dieser landstraße töteten die
mutmaßlichen täter die jungen beamten
durch kopfschüsse die tatwaffen offenbar
eine schrotflinte und ein jagdgewehr die
staatsanwaltschaft geht davon aus dass
beide geschossen haben der 32 jährige
tatverdächtige räumte ein schüsse seien
gefallen doch er selbst habe nicht
abgedrückt es gehört nicht zu unserer
vorstellung von deutschland
dass jemand auf offener straße mit
jagdwaffen andrang zu schießen und das
feuer eröffnet bloß weil er vielleicht
beim wildern erwischt wird deswegen ist
der fast verstörend die grausame tat
erschüttert die kolleginnen und kollegen
und die eltern der opfer und hat dann
schon die tränen in den augen und man
kann auch wenn man die mutter um abend
muss man sehr also wir hatten auch meine
innerlich bewegt hat an das geht einem
sehr nah tiefe trauer am tag nach der
tat die ermittlungen zu den polizisten
morden in der westpfalz gehen weiter
einer der gefährlichsten
schwerverbrecher deutschlands steht
erneut vor gericht der frühere
reemtsma-entführer thomas drach der 61
jährige soll in vier fällen
geldtransporter überfallen und dabei
zwei wachmänner angeschossen und schwer
verletzt haben ein komplize ist mit
angeklagt drach hatte 1996
jan philipp reemtsma entführt den erben
einer tabak dynastie und ein millionen
lösegeld erpresst dafür bekam er 14
einhalb jahre haft
vor genau einem jahr putschte sich das
militär in japan die macht und geht
seitdem mit harter hand gegen die
demokratiebewegung vor die vereinten
nationen machen die militärs für
mindestens 1500 tote verantwortlich auch
von willkürlichen verhaftungen und
folter ist die rede trotzdem leisten
immer wieder mutige menschen widerstand
auch heute am jahrestag normen odenthal
berichtet
sie erobern die straße wenigstens für
ein paar minuten eine flashmob
demonstration verabredet über digitale
kanäle und flüsterpost janet geht voran
schreit kämpft für demokratie sie
riskieren ihre freiheit ihr leben die
mit herunter ist gnadenlos dann wird die
sache zu heiß schnell verschwinden
abtauchen überleben
benitez steht ganz oben auf der
fahndungsliste der polizei wechselt
seine verstecke regelmäßig
die runter macht jagd auf uns wenn wir
protestieren sie versucht uns mit autos
zusammen schießt auf uns ja wir haben
angst um unser leben aber es ist
wichtiger dass wir uns gegen die
diktatur wäre
vor einem jahr putscht das militär reißt
die macht an sich lässt tausende in
gefängnissen verschwinden auch auf
sanssouci wurde die ikone der
demokratiebewegung zu mächtig
unkontrollierbar für die generäle sie
bekommt hohe haftstrafen auf den
strassen wochenlang gewalt eine schlacht
mit ungleichen mitteln das militär
schießt scharf tötet gezielt so der
vorwurf die furchtbare bilanz heute
ein jahr nach dem putsch des militärs
ist die gewalt und brutalität in myanmar
noch schlimmer geworden hat sich noch
mehr verbreitet
sanktionen treffen die machthaber aber
auch das land die versorgung wird
schwieriger armut wächst corona tut das
übrige das militär hat gerade wieder
frieden versprochen und freie wahlen es
gibt nicht viele die daran glauben
ja und im nachbarland china beginnen in
drei tagen die winterspiele und die
sportler aus aller welt die freuen sich
natürlich darauf und hoffen dass ihn
corona nicht noch einen strich durch die
rechnung macht die zahlen der gemeldeten
infektionen in der olympia- blase peking
sind bislang relativ gering
ein großteil der deutschen olympia
delegation es in china angekommen heute
morgen landeten insgesamt 97 mitglieder
des team deutschland am flughafen von
peking
dazu zählen auch 40 athletinnen und
athleten wie beispielsweise die
skispringer karl geiger und katharina
althaus sowie die biathleten denise
herrmann und benedikt doll langläuferin
katharina hennig ist schon seit sonntag
vor ort wir können sie nicht persönlich
treffen nur per video angst vor
ansteckung corona bleibt thema nummer
eins also wir waren jetzt schon mal
heilfroh dass wir alle gesund und munter
hier drüben angekommen sind da haben wir
schon in deutschland oder in der schweiz
noch gesagt wenn man das geschafft haben
ist die halbe miete trotz alledem bleibt
natürlich das risiko dass hier noch
irgendwer etwas einfällt gestern gab es
24 neue fälle davon sechs innerhalb der
blase insgesamt stieg die zahl seit dem
januar auf 200 ob es unter den heute
eingereisten deutschen corona fälle gibt
ist aktuell noch nicht bekannt
in der fußball bundesliga sollen jetzt
vielerorts die zuschauer obergrenzen
angehoben werden bremen lässt mehr fans
in die stadien sachsen zieht mit berlin
könnte folgen und die nordrhein
westfalen müssen vielleicht die richter
entscheiden 11.000 fans statt fast
leerer ränge rb leipzig darf im nächsten
heimspiel das stadion wieder zu einem
viertel auslasten das hat das land
entschieden bei zweitligist bremen sind
am samstag zehntausende in nrw hat der
erste fc köln einen eilantrag beim
oberverwaltungsgericht in münster
eingereicht der verein will wie auch
bielefeld und der bvb schon am
wochenende mehr als die aktuell
erlaubten 750 fans die chancen der
verein ich direkt bekommen stehen
ziemlich gut denn es liegt auf der hand
dass in einem großen stadion mit bis zu
80.000 menschen auch mehr menschen
corona sicher platz finden können als
beispielsweise in einer kleinen halle
deswegen kann es gut sein dass die
starre obergrenze die wir aktuell in
nordrhein westfalen habe gegen den
grundsatz der verhältnismäßigkeit
verstößt wann eine entscheidung
getroffen wird ist offen bis morgen
abend kann aber das land schon die
richtung vorgeben
die american football legende
schlechthin hört auf tom brady
quarterback star der tampa bay
buccaneers der mann mit den genialen
pässen und sieben super bowl siegen
geendet nach 22 jahren seine karriere
als bester schauspieler
was willst du da noch sagen tschüss
vielleicht zum wetter im süden bayerns
wird vor starkem schneefall und
schneeverwehungen gewarnt ansonsten
bleibt es wechselhaft mehr dazu gleich
von ersten viertel vor zehn das heute
journal mit christian sievers wir sagen
danke für ihr interesse wünschen ihnen
einen unbeschwerten abend und sind
morgen wieder da auf wiedersehen
[Musik]
schokolade und herzlich willkommen zum
wetter ja sie haben wahrscheinlich
mitgekriegt der januar war ganz schön
trüb und jetzt haben wir die daten dazu
tatsächlich gab es teilweise nur 31
prozent der des normalen sonnenscheins
quer über deutschland war es also eine
ziemlich trübe angelegenheit aber im
süden durchaus sogar mehr sonnenschein
genauso wie an den küsten und nach ganz
im osten hin wir schauen auf die nachts
da gibt es regenschauer teils auch
graupel und schnee der schnee der jetzt
staut sich hier an den am erzgebirge und
dann kann es durchaus längere zeit
schneiden genauso wie an den alpen hier
kommen gut 50 cm neuschnee zusammen dazu
die temperaturen minus 1 grad am
alpenrand und 7 grad ganz im westen
deutschlands und morgen schneit es an
den alpen weiter bei vielen wolken oder
auch im erzgebirge sonst zeigt sich
durchaus im nordwesten die sonne es
lockert auf bei höchsten temperaturen
von 3 grad im vogtland und 11 grad im
rhein-main-gebiet die kommenden tage ja
sind zu durchwachsen mit regen bei vier
bis zehn grad aber der wind ist nicht
mehr ganz so stark und spitzen am
samstag gibt es im westen etwas
sonnenschein ein schöner abend